what are you doing here
Dad I'm fine
what are you doing well look the
mistakes get made thank you I made a lot
of decisions that I probably shouldn't
have made it could lead to just a
horrible outcome we're in a better
position economically and politically we
are we still have real problems to me
it's not something that is difficult to
explain look there could be a laptop out
there that was stolen from me there
could be that I was hacked it could be
that there was the that it was Russian
intelligence it could be that it was
stolen from me not one serious
journalist has ever accused has ever
come to the conclusion that I did
anything wrong or that my father did
anything wrong thank you and and Trust
in the process by the way this thing
about a gun I didn't know anything about
it Secret Service figured out a way to
get over to the house I guess you get
asked I don't guess you get asked the
question are you on drugs you use drugs
I probably smoke more parmesan cheese
than anyone
I mean
I went one time for 13 days without
sleeping not a joke and smoking crack
and drinking vodka exclusively
incredible throughout that entire time
I'm proud of my son so darn proud
what what is there any breathing room
it's hard
look we've reduced drug prices
what's up internet people I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's April 27
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share and tap that
notification Bell if you haven't so that
occasionally especially if you're
watching on YouTube even though we want
you to be watching on Rumble you do
actually see our videos I'm going to
peel back the curtain for just a moment
and let you in on something in case you
weren't paying attention for the last
couple days if you've been otherwise
distracted although this appears to be
live to you it's actually pre-taped
because yesterday I hopped on a plane
and went halfway across the world or
it's probably almost more than halfway
across the world about a 12 hour plane
ride I am in Israel right now that's
right I am in the Holy Land I will be
there for about 10 days we're doing a
whole bunch of interviews and going to
the historical sites and and a bunch
more and then a couple days in Hungary
where I'll be doing something with
Jordan Peterson and some of the
officials there a lot of it will be
unraveled leveling as we're kind of
doing it in real time and we'll be
posting things all over if you want to
see some behind the scenes things please
do join us at reubenreport.locals.com
but we wanted to make sure that we had
enough content up for you while I was
away so we'll be filling filling in
things over the uh next uh 12 or 14 days
or so and uh before we get to what we're
doing today which is a slight dissection
of my friend Bill Maher the slow motion
conservative that's what I like to call
them I mean that with love Bill we're
going to do a little something with Bill
we're gonna do a Reuben report Community
Q a and uh and then I'm probably
somewhere eating hummus right now but
before we do let me talk to you guys
about ramp do you feel like your finance
software isn't cutting it do you want
the latest and greatest in financial
software to simply spend help you save
time and keep you from getting trapped
in busy work check out ramp ramp is the
corporate card expense management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket ramp
gives Finance teams unprecedented
control and insight into company spend
with ramp you're able to issue cards to
every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense
reporting so you can stop wasting time
at the end of every month ramps
accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to you'll never have to chase down a
receipt again and your employees will no
longer spend hours submitting expense
reports the time you'll save each month
on employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster ramp
saves you money businesses that use
ramps save an average of 3.5 percent in
the first year and now get 250 dollars
when you join ramp just go to ramp.com
Reuben that's rampram.com Ruben and now
back to me okay let's talk about Bill
Maher for just a moment I know some of
you say Dave you talk about Bill Maher
too much but I'm telling you guys even
if he never votes the right way the fact
that he is Doling out slow motion red
pills to his often NPC you know
non-playable character audience is a
good thing one of my frustrations with
the sort of last liberal types is that
they end up just repeating what
conservatives have been saying for many
many years they just repeat it years
later this is a really Primo example of
that here is Bill Maher on Real Time
with Bill Maher from a couple days ago
and they're talking about why black
celebrities aren't calling out the black
community which unfortunately in Chicago
and New York and many other places often
is uh killing each other it's black on
black crime it just is what it is
I I think that the moral valence is
clear it's terrible to commit a crime
and it's terrible to hurt people but
then the question is what do you do from
there well but why isn't anyone ever
talking to the like Chicago like most of
the the shootings are young black men
killing other young black men is that
not correct yeah that's correct okay
much more than than what the cops do
why doesn't anybody talk about that well
I mean why aren't there uh you know a
a hundred giant black celebrities who
would have the respect of those people
saying what are you doing to yourselves
why are you killing each other
[Applause]
this dishonors our community come on uh
we're better than this right
I feel like it's never addressed okay so
I will golf clap you there right Bill
Maher you're right why isn't the black
community talking about this internal
thing I I don't care if someone gets
killed and someone is shot and there's a
crime commit against somebody I don't
care about their skin color but in this
situation where we've Ultra racialized
everything when you look at the numbers
of shootings in Chicago on any given
weekend the reason nobody quote unquote
nobody talks about it is because it's
always black on black crime on any given
day you can open up Twitter and see in
New York City a a black guy uh pushing
an Asian woman into a subway nobody
talks about that this is not to be
racist obviously it's an actual issue
now it's interesting though the reason I
wanted to show it to you is because it's
not exactly that nobody's been talking
about this there have been many people
white black and otherwise who've been
talking about this for a long time I
would put Thomas Soul at the top of that
list uh of course there's Larry Elder
Candace Owens certainly has been talking
about it for a long time if we just want
to pick out black people but then there
are other people that have been doing it
for years Sean Hannity for many years on
Fox was talking about Chicago crime all
the time and everyone called him racist
for it it became a running gag on this
show how many people were shot in
Chicago this past weekend not to make
light of the people who were shot or
their skin color or anything else but to
show you that there's a real problem
here that because it doesn't fit the
racial lens of the corporate press it
does not get talked about but how about
this and maybe uh maybe Bill Maher will
have my friend Larry Elder on Larry of
course is running for president here is
Larry Elder I know you've all seen at
least portions of this video this was
this was the great red pilling of Dave
Rubin that has been seen you know
something like 200 million times this is
January of 2016. Lefty Dave Rubin at the
time trying to tell Larry Elder that
their systemic racism and a whole bunch
more and Larry lays it out
what what are they going for there well
they're what their goal the goal is to
tell black people that we're victims
that uh discrimination and racism remain
major problems in America when in fact
they don't uh and uh they want black
people to vote for the Democratic party
the Democratic party gets uh 95 of the
black vote uh and the reason they get it
is because blacks are convinced that the
number one issue facing the country
right now is social justice racist white
cops uh discrimination systemic racism
microaggression whatever new word they
come up with and it's a bunch of
nonsense the number one problem
domestically facing this country is a
breakdown of the family and President
Obama said that I didn't uh a a a black
kid or our kid not just a black kid a
kid raised without a dad is five times
more likely to be poor and commit crimes
nine times more likely to drop out of
school and 20 times more likely to end
up in jail so you're far more likely to
end up in jail without having a dad than
you are because of a white racist cop
for those of you that haven't seen it or
if you're new to this show that video
that hour-long interview was the
beginning of my red pilling as I said
it's been clipped and sent across the
internet a gajillion times and it was
like you know black conservative
destroys white libtard and when you're
that white libtard it's uh it's not that
fun uh but that really opened up my mind
to a whole bunch more as Larry kind of
eviscerated me with stats and I went
into I went into an intellectual uh
fight without being armed properly and
I'm very happy that it happened many of
you know if you read my first book that
you know that was not aired live it was
to tape and a bunch of The Producers at
the show we weren't independent yet we
were at Aura TV a bunch of The Producers
wanted me to cut the moment where he
really fillets me and I did not do it I
thought if I'm an interviewer I have to
I have to defend what is true I can't
just cut things out because they don't
make me look great and obviously the
rest is history but the point there is
uh my challenge now goes out to you Bill
Maher have Larry Elder on your show he's
running for president he ran uh for
governor in California and a recall that
did not go well but he had massive
massive support he is a good decent man
if you are concerned about black on
black crime and you want to elevate
voices from the black community I hate
that word but from the black community
Larry Elder would be one to put on there
and let's talk about this and why the
shootings are connected to the wider
cultural things that are related to
music and to TV shows that glorify
certain things but really more than
anything else just the family
just the family because we all know it
to be true if you have good role models
in your family you have people to look
up to it kind of keeps you going north
and if you don't then then things do
devolve from there so that is my
challenge that's how I'm laying it out
today the challenge is Bill Maher have
Larry Elder on Real Time with Bill Maher
and ask him that very question and let's
see what happens before we get to the
Reuben report Community Q a let me talk
to you guys about manscaped we're still
in April so they're still in the Easter
Passover moment and they want you to
know they've got a deal you can't pass
over this Easter season they've got the
tools to give you the beautifully
decorated eggs of your dreams just
because it's Easter time doesn't mean
it's okay to hide those bad boys behind
all that tall grass so make sure you're
downstairs lawn is mowed get yourself
feeling as sweet as candy by going to
manscape.com and getting 20 off plus
free shipping with code Dave inside the
ball care Bunny basket you'll find their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker 2.0
you're a nose hair trimmer crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all your goodies
April's Easter but it's also testicular
cancer awareness month manscaped has
partnered with the testicular cancer
society to bring awareness to testicular
cancer Men's Health and early cancer
detection manscape is committed to
raising awareness for the most common
form of cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and
giving support for Fighters survivors
and families impacted by testicular
cancer as part of their we save balls
initiative save 20 off and free shipping
with the code Dave at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code Dave at manscaped.com and now back
to me
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
here we go uh Ben says have you heard
car makers are dropping AM radio in new
cars you know I remember hearing about
this a couple years ago and I guess it's
begun already or it's fully kicking in
now or just AM radio is gonna slowly
slide off the dial something like that
you know I suppose look you can't stop
progress and we have progress well I
don't know that you can call this thing
progress but we all have a phone in our
pocket and in that phone you've got your
Spotify and your I heart radio and all
of that other stuff where you can watch
things on Rumble and YouTube and
everything else so AM radio is a
dinosaur of a certain
degree I would say on a personal note I
I have an affinity my memory of AM radio
is mostly driving around with my mom and
dad wherever maybe we're going to my
grandma's or aunt and uncle or whatever
and they'd be listening to AM radio and
it was mostly at the time it was these
guys the one guy that I remember
specifically is this guy Bob Grant I
think he was on 77 770 a.m I guess it
was WABC in New York and he'd do a
call-in show and these people would call
up and he was a conservative basically
and they'd ask him anything and he'd
start screaming at them and belittling
them and I just couldn't believe that
anyone would treat their audience like
that but the guy was on for many many
years if I'm not mistaken he passed away
a couple years ago but AM radio whether
it was rush or Hannity or Glenn Beck you
know there's plenty of people that are
still on there doing doing a lot of
great stuff you know Clay Travis and uh
and Bucks X and took over for Rush
um but you know nothing lasts forever
and you know we had betamax and then we
had VHS and then we had DVDs and then we
had Blu-ray and now we've got streaming
and it's just part and parcel of the
whole freaking thing Terry says do you
think this is the end of cable news or
will a Visionary group rise up that
wants a new 21st century Channel with
journalists reporting on both sides or
do we see the 21st century as following
Echo chambers of our own political views
I think partly what you're asking is
related to Tucker Carlson a lot of that
is unfolding at the moment and him
leaving Fox which is it just cannot be
understated I'm sorry it cannot be
overstated what a big deal this is the
number one highest rated host in cable
news history remember Bill O'Reilly had
that slot for probably 15 years
something like that on Fox and he was
number one for basically all those 15
years he left that slot was not
guaranteed to be number one you know a
time slot on a network will get you a
certain amount of people that just by
force a habit habit just turn on the
channel and there you go it's like the
chair is kind of worth a certain amount
of something but Tucker Tucker exploded
from there Tucker started talking
talking to a certain segment that I
would say was was obviously very much a
Maga segment but was also something
wider than that and I think he was doing
you know actual journalism you know
within the construct of that he's giving
you his opinion and all of those things
anyway I happen I happen to like Tucker
my guess uh if he has not announced it
by as I said we're pre-taping this but
if he has not announced it yet and I
doubt he has like my guess is he's going
to go independent so we shall see what
happens with that but five years ago or
what is it seven years ago almost he sat
down in my house in my garage and he
said uh you know basically Dave you're
you're doing it you're doing the right
thing so I think maybe I have a little
something to do with the seed of
Independence in Tucker which is great
but to fully answer your question I do
sense that things are just going to keep
going in their own directions it's just
the way it is I don't know that a
network that had a real plurality of
opinion could survive in in a
traditional sense that we think of a
network because people are so addicted
to their side I try to break through the
that as much as I can here it's getting
difficult because Democrats won't talk
to me I could see a group of independent
creators coming together to figure out
something that is bigger than all of
them independently maybe that's
something I should be doing Phoenix are
you taking notes toei says since you're
going to Israel uh set the center of the
three major religions what are your
thoughts on what role religion still has
if any in America and our lives today so
as we're taping this right now I as I
said I am in Israel we're in Jerusalem
for the first I think four days then
we're basically based out of Tel Aviv
for the next week and bouncing around
the country from there it's an absurdly
tiny country if if you have not looked
if or if you didn't see my interview
with BB Netanyahu pick up a map just
Google it Israel is the size of New
Jersey literally New Jersey which I
think is our second or third smallest
state in the United States and it's in a
pretty rough area but I mentioned that
because you can basically get anywhere
not basically a hundred percent you can
get anywhere from the northernmost tip
where you're basically hitting Syria to
the southernmost tip where you're
hitting the Sinai which is part of Egypt
you can do that all within a day you can
do it within a matter of hours and east
to west it's even more narrow so we're
going to be bouncing around and going to
all the sites and we're going to go to
the Western Wall and we're going to go
to the Church of the Holy Sepulcher and
we're going to go to the Old City the
Jewish quarter in the Christian quarter
in the Armenian quarter and we're going
to do all of that stuff and we're going
to go to the Museum of Tolerance and all
of the things and we're going to get as
many interviews as possible on the
religion front
I would say this if you don't believe in
something
you will fall for anything somebody
famous said that was that uh Yogi Berra
or something
um and I think that partly what we're
hap what's happening in our society
right now is we've we've broken
everything that we once believed in our
our society you know Ben Shapiro wrote a
great book about this
um and it's basically that our society
has broken all of the things that we
came from all of the traditions of
learning whether they were uh you know
thinking in an Aristotelian manner from
Greece or whether they were the ideas of
you know one God from Jerusalem these
ideas came together they created Western
society that has given so much human
flourishing in these last 250 years and
as we've strayed from that we suddenly
don't know if what boys and girls are so
I've found for me personally in these
last couple years uh the people of Faith
generally are much nicer and Kinder and
more decent and and trying I would say
to live up to their ideals rather than
the purely secular people who generally
are angrier and more hysterical and were
the ones that were pushing for more
mandates and injecting people with
things uh you know the story when I went
to uh Liberty University and I spoke in
front of 14 000 kids at convocation and
I obviously have differences in my
lifestyle and my political beliefs than
them but they were just so unbelievably
welcoming so I think a little uh
Resurgence of of some level of belief
and how you then work that into your
life related to the Traditions that you
come to from whether you're Jewish or
Christian or whatever it might be
um I think that would probably be good
and I'm looking forward to to taking
part of some of that while we're in
Israel uh Carey says hey Dave related to
Tucker Carlson do you think Fox will get
a dose of the same medicine that
Anheuser-Busch received after the bud
debacle that would be sweet well look
first off at the moment from me taping
this right now it's a little unclear to
me like exactly what went down now
obviously that's going to leak out did
he get into a fight with somebody there
does this have anything to do with the
Dominion lawsuit is it a combination of
those things has he been plotting an
exit for a long time he actually just
signed the contract his last contract I
think like a year ago so this is this is
is definitely a shocker did he want to
say something on air that they wouldn't
let him say and that gave him the out
I don't know
um let me say this just broadly in terms
of fox look I go on Fox all the time you
know probably four times a week
something like that they don't ask me
what I'm gonna say I go on live I do
whatever I want whether it's on with
Gutfeld or Dana Perino or Hannity or
when I've done Tucker or whatever else
so I have no problems with with Fox as a
network and I also think Fox generally
speaking is doing something far far
closer to actual journalism
that MSNBC and CNN and blah blah blah
and the only reason people focus on Fox
so much is because they just want their
competition to be taken out right more
people watch Fox all that being said uh
I think if Tucker goes independent I
think it's great for Independent Media
and I think it's great for uh let's just
say the future of our ability to
communicate with each other without the
middleman
um but you know Fox get you got to give
Fox one thing they surprise people right
they did not expect bill you know Tucker
to take over and be number one the way
he was so you just never know what these
guys they've still got the number one
late night show in Gutfeld they're still
crushing across the board will there be
some people that part ways from them now
probably but we'll see what happens on
the other side uh Tim says do you think
we will still be able to get your show
or use locals or Rumble it feels C11 is
passed in Canada so for those of you
that don't know Bill C11 we've talked
about it a little bit here it gives the
Canadian radio television
telecommunications commission say that
five times best unprecedented regulatory
authority to monitor monitor all online
audio visual content so basically if you
are a YouTuber or a rumbler or you're
somebody like Ezra Levant from the rebel
and you're trying to put stuff up they
can be watching it and taking it down
and finding you it's an absolute assault
on free speech and free expression in
Canada I can tell you this Rumble which
you know Rumble started in Canada we are
now based in Florida but there is a
strong Canadian presence we have plenty
of people in Canada that work for us
Rumble is going to fight like no company
you have ever seen before to make sure
that our content is being able to be
seen by people of Canada as just like
people in India and people in Mexico and
people in Sudan that is the plan there
are always ways to build a better
mousetrap to get around some of the
government's nonsense but it's an
absolute assault coming from the
quote-unquote Liberals the the Justin
Trudeau liberals in Canada and it's uh
it's deeply upsetting and I think that's
why I meet so many Canadians here the
free state of Florida Tony says curious
your thoughts on the Bud Light marketing
VP taking the leave of absence do you
think the boycott worked or is this just
another attempt by Anheuser-Busch to
sweep things under the rug I do sense it
worked the fact that at one point they
had lost as much as 7 billion in market
share I think as it's gone up a little
bit I think this is going to stick I
think people have just had it with that
nonsense and it's not like the product
is that great right like no one's really
walking around going Bud Light is the
most amazing beer right it was sold as a
frat boy beer right and what you're in
college you're in a frat you don't have
money you drink cheap piss like beer
that's what that's what it is it's not
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A people love that
chicken sandwich yes it's true when we
have Chick-Fil-A around here I have to
take the rest of the afternoon off
because I can't move but people love
Chick-fil-A right so they couldn't
boycott it effectively right Chick-fil-A
sales actually went up it was like a
complete rubber band on that uh Bud
Light I think is going to sell suffer in
a different way there are so many
freaking beers out there like how many
fried chicken sandwiches are there from
from uh chains you know I guess
McDonald's has one Burger King has one
but they don't focus on the chicken
right they clearly don't focus on the
chicken Chick-fil-A focuses on the
chicken there are so many beers beer
brands out there Connor how many beer
brands would you say there are 20
there's got to be at least 20
000. probably a lot of them you know
what I mean so I think they're in
trouble I really do think they're in
trouble uh Graham of course Bud Light is
just one you know vertical off
Anheuser-Busch they have a million other
beers they they've bought up a lot of
small breweries so like they will figure
out a way to survive
Graham says did you happen to see the 60
Minutes interview with Ray Epps on
Sunday any thoughts on that so I did not
see it other than the clips that I've
seen online which were somewhat brief
and I just didn't have time to get into
it this week with the travel coming and
just everything else and then and the
boys have been a little under the
weather it's been kind of nutty here but
the fact that 60 Minutes tried to make
Ray Epps look like a good guy when
they've gone out of their way to
demonize everyone related to January 6
and now you have the guy who was on
video basically calling for violence
pointing people in the way of the
capital and everything else and he's the
guy they're trying to make like look
like the good guy
need I say more gamma says Elon Musk
says that Anthony fauci should face
trial for the crimes he has committed
against the American people do you agree
with him I do actually
um look I don't like the idea of people
being hauled in front of uh of Courts
and I don't like the idea of sort of
unnecessary punishment or anything like
that however what fauci did the amount
of documented lies
documented lies that the NIH has nothing
to do with the Wuhan lab that masks work
that masks don't work that vaccines work
like the amount of stuff that this guy
as a as an unelected bureaucrat pushed
on the people of America is incredible I
would say you know what maybe maybe
instead of putting them on trial as if
putting him in jail I don't know that
that solves anything how about we just
cut his government pension which if I'm
not mistaken is over 400 Grand a year
how about we just sorry Anthony fauci
you can get one more year we won't we
won't be dicks about it you can finish
up calendar year 2023 with your 400
Grand plus the undoubted millions that
he made off of somehow all of this like
they always make money right so how
about that wouldn't that be something uh
Kathy says have you been to Israel
before how does it make you feel more in
touch with your faith uh yes and yes
I've been to Israel probably four times
uh first in 1997 then I went back and I
think around
2000 and then my sister actually uh
married her husband in Israel in Tel
Aviv in the old city of yaffa that was
probably about 12 years ago or so uh my
brother-in-law ass off is the CEO of
locals he's the one that when I had a I
didn't know what to do I was like we got
to go independent how do I build my own
patreon and stuff was a startup guy
obviously a lot of startup people at
Israel and he was like we'll do it and
we did it and and now he is he's running
locals and has a lot to do with what's
going on on the rumble side and then I
was last in Israel in 2015 and I did a
speaking gig in Tel Aviv and I was there
for about a week yes I'm really looking
forward to it I'm looking forward not
only to being in Jerusalem and the
religious side of things but you know
just relative to all the things that we
talk about on this show understanding
history understanding where good ideas
come from I think also understanding the
geography of that part of the world is
important
um also the blend you know I always talk
about the the sort of push and pull and
the tug of liberalism and conservatism I
think Israel is sort of a I would say a
living breathing example of that right
it's it's a place that's ancient and old
with filled with really old ideas from a
long long time ago Ten Commandments kind
of stuff and flee in Egypt and and all
of that uh combined with a country
that's become a massive uh leader in the
tech world and how you sort of blend
tradition and modernity I'm always
interested in that so I'm very happy
that I'm there right now Elizabeth says
is it hard to leave leave David and the
boys behind when you travel do you plan
on taking them with you when they're old
enough to travel around so I was already
again I'm gone at the moment that I'm
taping this but uh yes I I've been
thinking boy are they even going to
remember me I'm gone for 15 days that's
that's like you know it seems like a
long freaking time
um so I will I will miss them obviously
we're gonna do plenty of face times as
long as you know time differences and
everything allow for it
um as far as them traveling with me in
the future I mean of course we'll we'll
do some things together I think this
year if we're able to pull off any
degree of Off the Grid August Dave and I
might try to do just like even five days
solo and we'll give the boys to grandmas
and see what happens
um but yeah eventually looking forward
to doing actual family trips probably
not Disneyland we will go to Sea World
we're going to be a Sea World Gatorland
family mostly Gatorland and uh yeah
getting them out there and you know put
them on some skis and see what happens
uh Amy says what is more concerning
traveling to a country that is regularly
bombed by Foreign terrorists or
traveling to U.S cities like New York
City LA and Chicago where people are
regularly terrorized by his own
residence I mean I have to be totally
honest with you I I have no fear of of
traveling to Israel you know Israel
right now
there were a couple of rockets shot in
from from Lebanon uh like a week or two
ago uh but right now Israel is dealing
with some internal strife relative to
this judicial reform that Netanyahu has
been trying to pass so my hope is that
that's kind of calmed down just so that
we're not part uh you know like I just
don't want to be part of protests
everywhere in Tel Aviv and that that
kind of thing I would just rather it be
calm and enjoyable and be there for the
purposes of being there but that's what
a democracy is all about right the
people can share their voice but I don't
have fear that uh Hamas is gonna you
know come get us or anything else like
that but I will tell you having been in
San Francisco I was genuinely fearful on
the streets genuinely and and New York
City does not feel the same and
certainly Chicago wouldn't either what a
depressing uh thing that is to say you
know one of the interesting things
actually about Israel when they do that
like World happiness index that they do
every year Israel always comes usually
in the top 15 of happiness and you'd go
well wait a minute you know they've got
Rockets shooting in from the north and
Rockets from the south suicide bombers
and stabbings and all of those things
and you might might wonder like how does
that work and having been there a few
times it's like these people for the
most part they're like well we just have
to keep living yeah a bomb just hit the
backyard but we we got to keep living
and we have to keep celebrating that and
you know a lot of other cultures uh have
disappeared over time right but for some
reason these people are still there it
makes you wonder Kuma says there's an
anniversary celebration coming up for my
fine arts department one of the
activities is karaoke what song should I
sing for my radical Lefty friends you
know what you could sing for your
radical Hefty friends because this is
the antithesis of the Lefty project you
should sing Frank Sinatra's My Way right
the whole song he did it his way and he
has no regrets it's one of my favorite
songs My that's a top Fiverr for me and
that's it regrets I have a few well I
said he had no regrets he has a few but
but not too many to mention you see the
point not too few to mention but not too
few to mention too many to mention wait
regrets I have a few but not
too many to mention yeah the point is
the guy's all right all right nobody's
perfect okay communist guy
have you seen the birth Gap documentary
synopsis 70 of the countries in the
world have birth rates uh which have
fallen below replacement rate and all
countries are failing Israel is one of
the few Nations on Earth which still has
a healthy birth rate what can we learn
from them uh well you know what I'll
talk to the people in Israel about that
uh but yes especially on the religious
side people have an awful lot of kids
which creates actually another set of
tension that we'll probably see a bit of
in Israel which is that the religious
community is growing and growing and
growing and to your point the secular
Community they don't replace themselves
as much as they're shrinking Japan has a
massive problem with this
they have an aging population and they
are not replacing themselves I haven't
seen the documentary but Elon Musk has
talked about it quite a bit about the
replacement situation in general that we
are not you know there's this fear
amongst the lefties who are making
everybody fearful of everything
um that we're going to have this
overpopulated planet and every sci-fi
movie is about an overpopulated Planet
so we have to go somewhere else
somewhere else but wouldn't it be
interesting if actually the reverse is
what happens and we have a depopulated
planet and and societies and Nations
can't continue because there aren't
enough people wouldn't that be something
write that story somebody
uh Sarah says where do you see yourself
in five years
you know it's hard to say like I love
doing this I love doing this I I have
never in my life loved doing what I do
more and know that I'm I'm working with
the right people and building the right
things and I'm excited for the future
that Rumble and locals have and that
we're part of something interesting
we'll see where the the 2024
presidential race goes and maybe I can
have some involvement in in something
that would be beyond that I mean I think
there's there's a whole bunch of things
um
I'm good on the family front and I like
being a dad and it's stressful and and
tiresome and crazy but it's it's really
wonderful and joyful and happy and
Reinventing and all of those things too
uh I can tell you this I will be in
Florida there's no chance of leaving
Florida so I'll absolutely be in Florida
but I would I would imagine I'll be
doing this show maybe some we've
ventured out into some other uh some
other things you know we're working on a
whole bunch of things
um but you know hopefully look a nice
ending to the whole story I don't know
if it's in five years or ten years or 20
years but a nice ending is wow we really
got some wins we course corrected this
whole thing and uh gosh Dave you could
you could go out and take a walk into
the woods and we'll see you when we see
you wouldn't that be a nice ending
Tiffany says oh I guess I uh already
answered this one what's your favorite
Frank Sinatra song it is my way but uh
how about Luck Be A Lady there's a line
about blowing on another guy's dice
pretty funny if you think about it
because she's at the casino and she's
with some other guy and you got it
uh guys if you have not subscribed
please do it rumble.com if you want to
rumble.com Ruben reporting if you want
to play along during our q and A's if
you want to see some behind the scenes
stuff from the Holy Land join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with Constantine kissing is up
on locals well the full thing's up on
locals part two's up on uh Rumble and
YouTube we leave you with the elderly
man pretending to be president there's
no post game show today because I'm not
actually here
see you soon
we hold these truth to be still for
evident all men and women created by
that so you know this you know the thing
and by the way you know I should
understand and it get hot I got a lot of
I got hairy legs that that turn that
that that that that that that that
turned
about a blonde in the Sun and the kids
used to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was traded
then watch the hair come back up again
hey look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about kids jumping on
my lap and I've Loved kids jumping on my
life
[Music]
foreign